well have you recently dined in many
many viewers saying they are choosing to
eat at local restaurants and waiting a
little longer now than expected eight
news now reporter sally jaramillo spoke
to some businesses who say it's all due
to one popular trend
[Music]
a lot of takeouts especially now that
people don't want to you know be driving
around
and so start getting very popular again
javier barajas is the owner of el toro
ella capra a new restaurant that just
opened two months ago near decatur and
russell when we built this one
we we built a separate room for only
four to go during the pandemic takeout
became extremely popular and with that
popularity those choosing to diamond
are having to wait a little longer
baracka says at the time when dining was
closed takeout was the only option now
people have incorporated that into their
lifestyle we have a special parking for
them that if they don't want to get out
of the car
we bring the food to them it's easier
dining in
when you put it to go food it takes
longer for the cooks and so affect the
people that die name liam frederick is
the general manager for mama bird's
southern kitchen he says during peak
hours those who dine in are waiting
around 20 to 25 minutes we have been
finding ourselves
limiting to go orders that way we are
able to manage both the
to-go's and in-house dining to kind of
smooth things out frederick says with
their expansion and the way they operate
now they're definitely geared towards
take out people don't want to go out and
drive as much
going back to work so i think people are
going to stay more at home and want to
order food out sally caramillo live
local now